pac-man's a loser pac-man's a loser
pac-man's a loser
like that this is just look at that
alex jones is lying to you that might
come as a shock man
[Music]
jones has fake colors jones has fake
callers jones has fake callers jones has
fake callers this is just a specific
this is just
this is just
this is just
corporate takeover censorship d banking
arrest tyranny
[Music]
corporate tank over censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that look at that corporate tank
over censorship d-banking arrest tyranny
look at that look at that
corporate takeover censorship d-banking
arrest tyranny
look at that
look at that look at that pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser pac-man's a
loser pac-man's a loser and he's a
disgrace and he's a disgrace
and he's of this christ and he's a
disgrace look at that look at that
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pagman
look at those eyes man that that's that
that dude is gone
that is a freaking predator right there
who thinks he's smarter than you and
he's better than you and he's gonna beat
you he thinks oh joe rogan
[Music]
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of bathrooms
what on earth is going on with trump and
toilets
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
documents that donald trump was flushing
down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumpster
elements of
bathrooms times
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
[Music]
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david pakman
he is a baby
[Music]
david patman
he is a
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what what are we talking
about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman
they're emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but holy whoa
whoa jesse will we we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman obeying
a male dog but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pacman
he is
[Music]
all right welcome everybody we we just
don't have time to sit here and to
listen to songs all day i mean i would
love to be in such a position to be able
to do so
uh but we're not we're just not and i
want to welcome everybody here to the
stream
i am making my triumphant and um
principled defiant i would even say
return to streaming it has been insane
lately with the baby
uh with my girlfriend rehospitalized
with my fiance they were both the
girlfriend and fiance both back in the
hospital it was crazy
um and uh people asking how is fathering
it is uh it's it's a mess
it's very complicated and you know i
mentioned like i got a couple diapers
thinking like i don't really know i
don't know how many i need i'll get a
couple you know what i mean and it turns
out sometimes you need a couple diapers
within five minutes
um and i'm talking about the baby i'm
not even talking about trump here
it can get very very weaponized so
anyway i've had to make a very big
investment
in uh diapers and um you know one funny
this is kind of a funny thing
we used
to suspend the infant over the toilet
yeah we used a um
we were just so exhausted
that in order to not have to remember
like when did the baby last eat
when did the baby last go to the
bathroom we adopted a code
for diaper changes where we would make a
note of the time and then we would use a
code we would use the numbers one and
two now do i need to explain what the
code is can anybody tell me
is that do i need to the code is one and
two and you tell me whether that's an
easy enough i don't need to explain that
okay
we once had this is a you know
a uh a two one is like that's child's
play a two one you're dealing with the
two and then in the midst of it there's
a one and you to clean up the whole
thing okay two one is like nothing all
right
um
we at one point had
a
two two one two
a two two one two
all as part of the same diaper change
and uh i actually called mike pillow and
i was like this seems like it's gotta be
fraudulent there's no way that you could
have a two two one two
um but
it can happen the two two one two can
happen so needless to say
i said we've gotta stop the count that's
it don't don't we need to end it there
can be nothing more after a two two one
two
all right very good
um
peterson just like most republicans
can't even make sense of what they're
saying we're gonna talk about jordan
peterson today so relax okay everybody
relax everybody relax
david are you excited to sample subway's
new menu no i don't know anything about
that
subway new menu i haven't been to subway
in 20 years
but let's look at it
um i'll add it to my list i have so many
things to go over with you guys okay
let's just jump right in so let me set
the parameters of this live stream just
so nobody's underwhelmed but also so
nobody's overwhelmed we are going to
be looking it's like a clean out the
computer type day if you guys ever
listened to howard stern you would know
every once in a while you need to clean
out the computer type day
and um today is such a day i have so
many things here that i want to go over
and so i'm really glad that you're here
and that's what we're going to be doing
i do want to say a quick thank you to
kenneth mankowski who just signed up on
my website and his new member number one
and real quick over on twitch a bunch of
people uh signing up there
life is good blueberry babe guitar
goddess cosmos jen here cortina milo
wilde it's some of our best friends hell
muffin and aviator
uh aviator is from highland park
illinois which we will get to okay so
that's eight putting us at nine now i
will tell you right now if we get to a
hundred today i will commit to another
stream this week maybe even the prompt
rally in um what's the name of that
state way it's way up there alaska
there's a prompt rally in alaska on
saturday maybe that will be it okay
so i will commit to another stream this
week as hectic as things have been all
right let's get right into it couple
other super chats real quick david
beautiful intro and songs as always
thanks for all you do hope you and the
family are doing well well thank you
brian
i grew up in highland park want to let
everyone know firsthand the thoughts and
prayers aren't enough we need nationwide
change yeah i tweeted yesterday
people have been praying supposedly
and yet we still had a shooting and so
did people pray to the wrong god did the
wrong people pray did they not pray
enough times did they not pray correctly
did they not pray long enough were there
conflicting prayers that cancelled out
in other words if eight people pray for
a shooting and seven people against it
does the shooting happen
very strange
and we don't have the answers we don't
have the answers all right
thanks to badness and jack chrissy as
well as fwasti for gifting three that
puts us at 14. i really appreciate that
okay let's just jump right in i've been
asked to review this this is sort of
interesting this is the there's a media
bias chart which the david pakman show
is now privileged enough to be
considered part of we are now considered
significant enough i guess where we are
part of this and i thought we would
compare where we are on this chart to
other of our contemporaries okay
good now what is ad fontes i have no
idea first we should figure that out ad
fun test media is a colorado-based media
watchdog organization primarily known
for its media bias chart fair rates
media sources in terms of political bias
and reliability
founded in 2018 by a patent attorney
vanessa otero with the goal of combating
political polarization and media bias
they use a panel of analysts across the
spectrum of politics to evaluate
articles for the chart okay so
uh they say they are nonpartisan
fine i mean it seems reasonable enough
the chart has been criticized by people
on the left and right according to otero
a lot of people on the left will call us
neo-liberal shills and people on the
right are like you guys are leftists
columbia journalism review questioned
the thoroughness of the chart
saying that the 5 to 20 stories
typically judged represent but a drop of
mainstream news outlets production
that's fair that's fair
um alex jones called it a dying dinosaur
media's extreme liberal bias
okay so anyway that's what it is let's
now examine it now one of the things
that i found very interesting is
they have this box here
and you guys know that like for example
on my website one of the key things is
it this box is this a gift so you know
i'm very partial to boxes in general i
see a box and i think that's interesting
okay so when you look for the david
pakman show
we are right on the edge of what is the
most reliable for news section i love
that we're not even news we're
commentary and we are just on the
periphery here of what would be
considered where you kind of want to be
for news i guess or commentary that you
can trust now certainly we skew left
that's absolutely true
we are not the hyper partisan left i
agree with that i'm not even a democrat
and we are not in the most extreme left
so far so good quite frankly i find it
flattering that me in a mic
in a room with this is a room by the way
and and by the way there is a rooftop
and i know now rooftops are a big deal
because of the shooting yesterday we'll
get to that i'm in a room with a mic
i don't have any clue what i'm doing
and we are on the periphery of the most
reliable for news entities i love that
okay
the panels are stolen from sam cedar it
is still a room okay now
let's see i don't know who else is on
this chart i haven't done this yet
let me know
who else we want to compare to and i'll
start searching for them just shout them
out who wants what do we want to look
next hassan okay let's see hasan is not
on here okay
next what else can we try to compare
ourselves to
crowder
louder with crowder beautiful louder
with crowder is in the worst box it's in
the red box you do not want to listen to
crowder i like this i'm flattered by
this and of course because this says
good things about me
i am predisposed to say good things
about it okay no so crowder is on the
hyperpartisan right and it is in this
red box where there is serious
reliability issues
and or extremism i agree with that
i agree with that
okay
let's go with sam sader okay let's check
that out the majority report with sam oh
uh oh
sam is outside the box guys
sam according to this is slightly
further left
with a high variation in reliability we
don't want that
we don't want that
all right but pretty close that's fine i
mean guys this is pretty close um
tucker
let's look at tucker fox news with
tucker carlson
tucker is not in the worst box but is in
a it's not a great box he is slightly
less partisan than crowder and slightly
more reliable than crowder using unfair
persuasion and propaganda now i disagree
with that to me oh wait a second no no
no
the dot oh wait no the dot where is the
dot
okay fine no this is okay so anyway
not quite as bad
uh tim poole let's see
the timpool daily show
is
notably less reliable than tucker
but slightly less extreme that's
interesting now tim poole claimed to be
of the left didn't he
it's interesting that he's actually
categorized on the hyper-partisan right
uh okay the young turks
tyt's the young turks
oh no
i gotta pay for this
i wasn't planning to do that
i don't even know what this is let's see
if it what if i just refresh it
oh my god look at this all right so
let's put pac-man back in
oh you know what i think as long as i
don't have them all up on the screen at
once it should be okay oh nope it's not
letting me maybe let's try a different
one
maddow no all right well guys we're the
experiment is over i'm not gonna sign up
for this on screen right now
but um
okay so anyway i think this is
interesting i'm absolutely flattered
that of the commentary shows
we are very favorably placed here and
again i'm going to remind everybody
i don't do a news show
i don't do a news show i do a commentary
show
okay
thank you very much everybody and
welcome all right we're moving on to the
next thing good
uh oh
mass shootings actually before we get to
mass shootings let me just say a few
other thank yous
thanks to blueberry babe
alice and cactus matt for the twitch
prime subscriptions putting us at 17.
i also want to say thank you to juan for
gifting a subscription on my website
kevin gouldy for gifting a subscription
and desiree de long each of each of you
have gifted a subscription
and if you would like a free
subscription i'm going to tell you this
right now and i'm only going to say it
once
we now have only 308 people waiting for
a free subscription that sounds like a
lot
that's the the lowest the waiting list
has been in months so if you would like
a free subscription go to
davidpakman.com
free membership
if you want to give a free subscription
i have 305 now people waiting
when you sign up on my website
joinpacman.com
check the box is this a gift you check
it to say yes okay but of course much
like on airlines when the oxygen masks
drop you want to put one on yourself
before helping those around you get
yourself a membership before getting
them for people around you so a very
very important message there
other super chats the onion
okay all right so we're off that we'll
check that out
still waiting on the republican news
machine to start obsessing over
unsecured ladders or the shooter wearing
women's clothing to obfuscate yet did
you guys know that sometimes there are
ladders
on the outside of a building we called
it a fire fire escape in the old days
and it's completely unsecured
and so forget about guns
we got we have to deal with the ladders
that's very very important now by the
way
if they go to the roof with a knife
i don't know how many people they're
killing down on street level
it seems that the most one with a
perfect throw
i'm just thinking
extemporaneously here
okay
but uh
banned doors and banned ladders and
ban all ban all machines by the way
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines indeed indeed okay
let's keep going because i do have so
many other things to talk about mass
shootings we have a sickness in this
country and many of you already know
that
in many countries
they have mass shootings they are
extraordinarily rare and because they
are so rare they make the the national
news
period okay in norway
if there's a mass shooting and sometimes
they have them remember there was okay
you know
it's major major news
in the united states we have two
categories of mass shootings we have
nationally noteworthy mass shootings
and then we have
sort of under the radar mass shootings
we had a lot of news about the highland
park illinois mass shooting why well
because seven people were killed and 29
were injured but then we had these other
minor mass shootings like i don't know
for example in uh corona queens
yesterday
four people were injured in a mass
shooting that one did not make national
headlines
this is like your everyday mass shooting
it's not an unusual one interestingly
you might be saying sir where is the
philadelphia one where the two police
officers were shot
two people
being victimized by a shooter
does not count as a mass shooting
it's not
imagine if in this list we included when
only two people are shot
it's only three or more
it's it's an incredibly sick country
that we live in some of us
um so
lest anyone think that there were only a
couple mass shootings yesterday on the
fourth of july there were actually one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten we had ten mass shootings
and we had at least one where there were
two victims that doesn't even show up on
the list because only two police
officers were shot
i what else is there to say this is the
gun violence archive website okay it's
gun violence archive
dot org
gun violence archive dot
org completely
nuts
absolutely and completely nuts
let me say thank you
to art vandelay
hippie chick and blueberry babe for the
twitch prime subscriptions numbers 21 22
and 23
i mentioned this earlier i'm trying to
get back onto us a committed streaming
schedule the podcast is back on i'm
trying to get back to streaming if we
get to 100 today 100 supporters i will
commit to another stream this week
potentially the prompt rally on saturday
night now
if you sign up at joinpakman.com that
counts as one it's a beautiful thing
you can use the coupon code indict to
get a discount if you sign up via twitch
that counts as one
and today only
if you sign up via patreon
it will count as
two understand
that's
patreon.com david pakman show very very
exciting all right let's get to some
other things
um
i was sent this video
apparently our friend kyle kolinsky of
secular talk fame
appeared on a show i'm not familiar with
and said that he is more critical
of joe rogan
than i am i have not previewed this
let's take a listen
and let's see if we can make heads or
tails out of it video it's a hard line
to walk right because you have to make i
wanted to make sure joe rogan himself
would listen to it and not immediately
dismiss it
is is kyle talking about a video he made
about rogan is that the context here
while also
letting my audience know and the people
who follow me already know rhonda
sanders is a piece of [ __ ] like hey man
this is serious and joe is wrong so you
had to walk that line and strike that
right tone i did that as good as i
possibly could none of it was
pre-planned out it's all just you know
however i react in the moment while
trying to lay out the argument in the
video and look i think i did a great job
about it and for people because this is
a criticism that i've seen of me
previously too and pac-man has even a
couple of times you know alluded to the
fact like others who have been on joe
rogan are very hesitant to criticize joe
well wait a sec i've never i've never
seen that's it that's weird i've never
seen kyle's appearances on rogan
nor am i aware
of whether he does or doesn't criticize
rogan when i said that i was alluding to
jimmy dore
but then i figured out i haven't even
alluded to it recently because then i
figured out like
well of course dorae won't criticize
rogan's right wing stuff because dorae
is a right winger
um
that's weird no i would love the
opportunity i haven't talked to kyle for
a little while i don't know what's going
on i am so busy including particularly
with the baby
the only rogan i've seen like in the
last
maybe year i watched um
what's the guy who the guy the author
who wrote this is your mind on plants
this is your brain on plants do you guys
know who i'm talking about michael
what's the guy's name
nobody knows michael pollan exactly
thank you alonzo i watched michael
pollan on rogan because i read that book
and the book is just extraordinary
um and then i saw
what else did i see on rogan
just stuff i've commented on because the
audience clips it but
i don't i was not alluding to kyle kyle
may be doing this or not i have no idea
but i've not seen kyle on rogan and i've
not seen kyle
criticize rogan nor am i aware that he
doesn't criticize him if that's if
that's the case uh but i guess kyle is
saying he's very critical of rogan check
my channel and compare to his channel
look at the number of videos that i've
done where when i disagreed with joe
rogan i did a segment disagreeing with
joe rogan i've done it a number of times
and i've done it quite a bit recently
there was one time where i think he said
something about
ubi how now he's against ubi i cover
that and i was like well i don't know i
guess i guess kyle's under the
impression i've at some point referred
to him but i have no clue what kyle's
doing i don't this is
somebody over the the fourth of july
weekend
they wrote to me and they asked me
whether i think that kyle dating crystal
ball is affecting his objectivity
i had no idea he was dating crystal ball
is is that like publicly known
i guess we might have a delay
it is publicly known okay i just heard
about it over the weekend
so anyway i have no idea what anybody's
up to i'm so busy and when i have time
uh i'm watching documentaries okay
so um
yeah okay so that's we've dealt with
that
let's look briefly at donald trump's
truth social which as many of you know
he doesn't always pronounce it correctly
truth essential apparently he's been
going completely nuts the last few hours
let's see what we've got
breaking trump lead biden by five points
in 2024 presidential election
trump's lead increased by three
neither of them has announced that
they're running so that's kind of
meaningless
i am honored to have blake masters i am
honored to have trump's endorsement oh
let's see this
blake masters is an incredible person a
very smart guy and an america first
fighter i endorse blake because he will
protect our border he stands for life
and he's strong on election fraud
frankly he's strong on everything needed
to keep arizona first mark bronovich and
jim layman on the other hand will only
let you down blake masters has my
complete and total endorsement i'm blake
masters and i approve this message whoa
i'm getting i don't know who the guy on
the right is
but oh hey winky dink media that's a
major youtube channel winky dink media
in the youtube audience with the message
troth essential which we love
um
i don't know who blake masters is but
i'm getting extreme predator vibes from
this guy major major major that is a
freaking predator right there yeah
um anybody know anything about him
yeah very strange so there's trump's
full endorsement
trump posted an article
called god bless the supreme court and
donald trump
okay
trump vindicated germany prepares for
chaos if russian gas is lost
what the hell are these articles this
one's from breitbart
after battling bureaucrats throughout
presidency trump gets last laugh against
deep state are you kidding me
trump with another a nazdag thing
okay
how can i be guilty of a crime when i'm
the only one who wanted to stop the
so-called crime by strongly recommending
10 000 plus troops to dc so
i know that you all probably know this
because you all have a clue what's going
on um trump continues to insist that he
recommended
asked for
requested requisition 10 000 troops for
january 6th there is no evidence that
such a recommendation or request was
ever made there's just no evidence of it
now is it possible he said it like to
melania or something i guess
um but there's no evidence that that
that happened hence the ma the
surrounding of the capital only to have
this recommendation rejected by pelosi
and the mayor of dc pelosi and the mayor
of dc are not in charge of capitol
police
but he claims that they are oh this is
real trash this is real trash so trump
completely losing it on truth central
another day another unhinged trump all
right let's update
beautiful there we go
um other messages coming in i want to
say thanks to 420 x weed bong who has
just signed up via twitch
and says where are the uncharged pickles
at uncharged piccolos also thanks to
hersafat
for the twitch prime subscription that
puts us at 25
and lastly a big thank you to gordon
hall gordon just gifted a membership at
joinedpakman.com
and his new member number 26 today thank
you very much
let's continue we have so much material
today so i want to keep going i don't
want to get bogged down
there's some new jordan peterson stuff
going on we're going to look in a moment
oh wait no actually sorry
let's look first people have asked me to
look at the new subway menu i have not
been to a subway in
hold on do anyone
17 years all right but is this new
promotion
going to be enough to get me to subway
subway unveils new subway series menu
with massive promotion
whoa
restaurant chain subway is giving away
up to a million six inchers to celebrate
the launch of its subway series it's
hailing it is the most significant menu
update in its nearly 60 year history
whoa
60 years
the 12 new creations which are divided
into the categories of their
categorizing they've got your cheese
steaks
your italianos
your chicken and your clubs
including such prolific names as the
great garlic bella matzah and the outlaw
july 12th from 10 to 12 local time up to
a million six inchers will be offered
across the nation
you can visit a subway and pick up a
free sandwich wow
these are the perfect combination of
meat cheese vegetables sauce and freshly
baked bread did they remove like the uh
what was it like a tire rubber from the
what was it that they had in the bread
that they removed some years ago turned
out they didn't really need that
anybody remember what the chemical was
no no no it wasn't sugar it was
something else
there was some kind of like industrial
chemical yoga mat it was oh something
used in yoga mats yeah that's weird
i prefer like five ingredient bread
that's my preference
guests will if you're worried you'll
still be able to order a customized
classic
yeah that's pretty interesting you know
what i like for uh for sandwiches let me
give you a sense of what i like in fact
let me see if i can find it this is
someone i follow on tiktok
these are the types of sandwiches i go
for let me see if i can find it here
uh
where is this
okay hold on here we go
the this is more like my thing
okay here's an italian
sandwich maker who makes beautiful
simple sandwiches okay let's check out
oh i don't know let's check out this one
[Music]
beautiful italian bread i mean that is
just the perfect bread
[Music]
i accidentally
[Music]
[Music]
you know what i've been off pork for a
while
um
i i may be going to italy next year i'm
i'm 99 sure
i'm gonna get back on
pork for the trip because these these
sandwiches these are like perfect
sandwiches
[Music]
[Music]
this is a sandwich
this is a sandwich okay do we wanna oh
but what about sir what about the bella
matzah from subway
no
okay it's a no by the way sometimes the
guy says what these cost sometimes these
are like four or five euro
four or five euro
let's look at one more
um i don't know one with a lot of views
let's see how about uh no that seems to
be him the guy answering questions
i don't know how about this one
see what we got
[Music]
it looks like it's a mozzarella with
like arugula maybe in it that's
fascinating
peppers and tomatoes
[Music]
guys
these are sandwiches okay
these are sandwiches that this is we
it's almost criminal i believe what
subway has done to this country under
the biden regime it's really really
triggering to me all right
let's move on
um oh look at these people saying
there's not enough stuff in it there's
no ranch and there's no mayonnaise and
you need a million ingredients no guys
you need simple good ingredients
simple good ingredients okay
man
all right super chats in ireland subways
bread can't be called bread due to its
sugar content most local delis are
better than the subway absolutely
absolutely
uh all right very good let's continue i
want to oh a big thank you to justin
lerman justin just signed up at
joinedpakman.com on the heels of my
sandwich opinions also thanks to kevin
gouldy who just gifted a subscription on
my website and his new member number 28.
all right i apologize for the uh delay
and let's get let's continue let's now
get to the jordan peterson stuff jordan
peterson who has for years said he's not
political
and he's not a right winger
not political
and not a right winger is now doing a
show with the extremely right-wing daily
wire we're gonna look at actually let's
first look at
the um trailer
this to me seems like it would be satire
but this is really the trailer for his
um for his new show and check this out
one of the things i tell young men well
on young women as well but the young men
really need to hear this more i think
you should be a monster an absolute
monster and then you should learn how to
control it
so a man who's capable of aggression but
has it under control is a way more
useful man than
one who cannot do that and so why would
anyone take advan uh take advice
um from jordan peterson at this point
i mean with everything that he
isn't he the the picture of instability
like i just genuinely don't know why you
would you would listen to him
so you're willing to go get a job but
you're terrified of an interview it's
like there's a dragon for you because
you want to fight the dragons that guard
the gates of the treasure that you wish
to attain
the productivity
requires aim orientation responsibility
discipline this is the exact type of
thing let me put that back on the screen
this is the exact type of thing where
you hear it and you you go this is so
useful he's giving me the list of stuff
this is just like this is awesome
you what you need aim orientation
responsibility and discipline
okay so like now what
great so now but what what disciplined
that willingness to work that
willingness to make sacrifices which is
the hallmark of maturity in the service
of a higher goal
it orients you solidly in the world if
you do that and it gives you a dragon to
fight
why do you want to grow up you want to
be illiterate
you want to be inarticulate you want to
be illiterate
you're going to have to negotiate
you're going to have to lead you're
going to have to convince this could be
a cigar commercial you're going to have
to think to say to a 18 year old
you're okay the way you are
that just deflates them
you know it's so funny he was just
ranting the other day about how it's
terrible terrible to tell
young people
about the bad things going on like it's
demoralizing to tell them that we're
ruining the planet
and now he's like telling them that
they're fine the way they are
is also terrible for them man it sounds
like everything's bad
you know when you go to the gym and you
start lifting weights well your body's
going to transform but it's not going to
do that if you just sit around you have
to face your being with the necessity of
transformation and then all sorts of new
things that you had no idea you were
capable of will make themselves manifest
those are the dragons you know the ones
that stand in the path that leads to the
light and you have to say to yourself
i will
do good
nonetheless
everyone great makes that decision
make that decision a powerful
declaration here from jordan peterson
that's for damn sure that is a freaking
predator right there because maybe
you're great
[Music]
really looking forward to that on uh
daily wire plus so anyway he did some
interviews i guess related to this
and they're pretty weird okay check this
out
hello everyone
i guess these aren't even these aren't
even interviews they're just kind of
like direct the camera things two days
ago i penned an irritated tweet in
response to one of the latest happenings
on the increasingly heated culture war
front now remember he quit twitter after
attacking me on twitter and then
attacking us
like a sports illustrated cover he quit
twitter so how is he already back on
twitter and getting into more trouble
in response to the decision of an
actress
actor
named ellen
elliott page oh boy
i am employing this awkward and
impossible naming style
because it is now apparently mandatory
and probably doing it wrong uh-oh this
takes him back to the beginning remember
we're i'm against compelled speech
he's against it
canada will not compel me
nonetheless as you're doing it wrong is
the whole point of what has been made
mandatory but also i'm trying to make a
point
i've essentially been banned from
twitter
as a consequence
i say banned
although technically i have been
suspended but he has been suspended
everybody
the suspension will not be lifted unless
i delete the hateful tweet in question
and i would rather die than do that whoa
he would prefer to die than delete a
tweet and hopefully it will not come to
that although who the hell knows in
these increasingly strange days wait is
he saying someone might kill him for not
deleting a tweet is that what he's that
that's outrageous
who even cares what he tweets
and then he did another one where he
raises not the the idea of nazis here
ex extremely principled and defiant i
know by participating in the whole
identity sharad it's a sharad that's
interesting i like that i might is that
a is that a valid pronunciation
let me see what that is
charade i don't see shirat is sharada a
canadian pronunciation i've never heard
that before
sharad
anybody know it's
british tell the french say
british pronunciation of charade that's
actually very interesting to me let me
listen the interviews with justice
charade oh it's it is the british
pronunciation beautifully done
all right let's continue
alan elliott has undoubtedly with his
her their so-called courage and remember
the white house itself is tweeted out at
every indication of believing in the
courage of those who transition
enticed many a poor confused adolescent
girl most likely to blame her emergent
pubescent self-consciousness confusion
and discomfort on being born in the
wrong body and believing that the
courageous self-affirming and morally
admirable root is hormonal treatment
sterilization subjugation to a lifetime
of expensive medical complication how
delightfully profitable is that and
anybody know what he's talking about
is this is this is transphobic right is
that i mean i guess that we can tell
misery
and i believe firmly that ellen
slash elliot or whatever the hell her
name or his name is
what a lunatic
oh my goodness
this is crazy
moral culpability imagine being like i'm
gonna get advice for my life from this
guy who's this
uh
sent for a loop
by
a trans person that
and finally with regard to the final
phrase
criminal physician i must say that i've
had some post-coital so to speak regrets
about that phrase what
post-coital
is this the teaching of transgender that
trump keeps talking about
it is clearly the case that the surgical
operation performed by the butchers who
butchered elliott
ellen was legal
so was it criminal
or not
were the operations undertaken by the
fascist physicians who carried out the
nazi medical experiments oh my god oh my
god
do you guys understand what he's saying
there
he's saying listen
it may be legal
to have i think what what is now called
gender affirming surgery
but what the nazis did in terms of
medical experiments was also legal in
third reich era germany so its legality
doesn't really it's funny would he apply
that to gay marriage would he go hey
before gay marriage was legal would you
go hey listen um
we uh
we don't
think that it's good
for
gay marriage to be legal
and it's illegal and that's it and then
people would go well sometimes things
are illegal that should be legal that
like that's the argument that he's
making here sort of but in reverse it's
all very very strange legal
yes
under the laws of the time right
but were they criminal
i'll leave that question up to you to
answer
and further
perhaps it might be objected
what about the damage done by
hypothetically leaving those confused
about their identity to dwell in their
confusion aren't we morally obliged to
intervene all right so anyway he just he
seems off his rocker i don't know how
else to say it it's it's very kind of
like coarse and in a sense dismissive
but he just seems like he's not really
in a place to be giving anybody advice
nor weighing in on anything of substance
now people are saying that he had a
conversation with dave rubin during
which he tried to tell dave rubin that
um basically like conversion therapy is
okay let's see if we can find that
jordan peterson
dave rubin that sounds pretty damn
interesting
uh see this now suddenly like you know
when when we announced that we were
having kids there was some pushback
online from oh wait a second here it is
right and more than that to make and
here's another perverse element of this
so many legislatures around the world
now have banned so-called conversion
therapy and to me this has been a
catastrophe now i know that there was a
small percentage mostly of
fundamentalist christian therapist types
in the u.s who were offering their
services to homosexual people who were
unhappy with their sexual orientation
and so often they were not unhappy their
parents were telling them
you got to go and be converted to be
straight they were even if it were true
oh my goodness this is like five layers
deep
no no
what
is this criminal is the question no it
was it wasn't you think kids were like
mom and dad i'm not super happy with my
sexual orientation
oh no worry little little jimmy we'll
send you to no
some parents were forcing their children
to go to this stuff
okay hold on a second
let's get rid of some of these there's
some people annoying me here oh
you could have a discussion about
whether that's ever appropriate or not
although i would say that's bloody well
between the person and their therapist
as far as i'm concerned but now that's
completely insane that's completely
insane
oh that's illegal and it's illegal to
the point where purpose in all your
years of clinical therapy and all the
patients that you ever saw i'm sure i
i'm sure you saw dozens if not hundreds
of gay patients did you ever meet a gay
man
who successfully de-gayed and then went
on to live a completely functioning life
no
by the way a functioning life like this
this is crazy
everything about this is crazy
so
now i it doesn't sound like peterson was
the one d gang anybody it sounds like
the question was just
did you meet someone who had been
de-gayed elsewhere man even that
language is crazy saying d gade is
almost like saying d loused you know
well i have to let me remove the lice
what even ruben's using crazy language
for this
wow
i had no idea that they were up to this
stuff
this is really really wild
dave rubin agrees with jordan peterson
that heterosexual marriage is the ideal
oh this i have to say
we have this notion that's rife in our
culture let's say that's insisted upon
that all families are equally are equal
and
i understand
the emphasis on that from the let's call
it the tolerance perspective
but i think that it's badly flawed in
one manner and i think this will be the
hardest thing probably for us to discuss
is that
now i guess this is hard because dave
rubin and his husband
are in the middle of having kids right
is that is that why it's going to be
difficult i'm trying to understand why
or is it just because dave reuben's gay
it's not clear why it'll be difficult
okay yeah well let's just see if we can
figure it out you can't flatten out
distinctions
without a tremendous loss and i don't
think it's possible to dispense with the
ideal
of heterosexual monogamy now as the
ideal yes that's so if we think well
there's an ideal individual who's
responsible and mature and far-seeing
and honest and honest traitor a good
player uh an honorable person honorable
decent person and then there's the
minimal requirement for a family that's
ideal and that's something approximating
heterosexual long-term heterosexual
monogamy and maybe you have two decent
people united together and then there's
a firm platform for children now the
problem with that as an ideal is that
we all fall short of the ideal and so
right half 40 of people are going to get
divorced and of the people who don't get
divorced a good percentage of them are
in pretty damn miserable marriages now
that doesn't condemn marriage but it
does show how difficult attaining that
ideal is and then there's going to be
people who lose their partners and raise
children alone and they're going to be
people who raise children alone by
happenstance or or choice
and they
it doesn't seem reasonable to
what would you say
um
put them outside the bounds of civilized
society let's say that by the same token
it doesn't seem reasonable to dispense
with the ideal yeah so maybe we need
something like well we know what the
ideal is it's a divine ideal in some
sense in that none of us can live up to
it
but then there has to be a space around
that ideal
where
the
individual differences and it sounds
like he's sort of saying
he doesn't believe
gay couples shouldn't have kids but it'd
be better if it was a heterosexual
couple but it's still okay for the gay
couple to have kids is that in seven
seconds the summary of what he's taking
three minutes to say
can you guys tell
maybe this is how his events go an hour
and a half
laws and peculiarities and
idiosyncrasies of people
aren't
treated so harshly that that becomes
counterproductive in and of itself it's
damning with faint praise but i don't
see no that's it that's it
that's it it's that's the meat of this
more than anything else that there is of
course there's an ideal of course there
is an ideal there has to be an ideal and
and if well there's nothing to aim at if
there's an automatic deal because if
they're if there isn't if the ideal
isn't two people
male and female in a heterosexual
relationship then what is it is it four
people
is it eight people is it one person like
instantly you go from that kind of
narrow ideal to an intense multiplicity
and we've certainly seen the problems
that are oh so it's like a slippery
slope that doesn't really seem true to
me like you know this is one of these
things where even if people so here's my
here's my uh belief about what people
think about this
you probably have a whole bunch of
people who agree
if you could just choose
what's best for a kid
you go
mom and dad together in a stable home
without a financial issue
okay and then you'd have a bunch of
other people who would go you know
uh i think that
same-sex parents
in a relationship in a stable home
without financial issues is just as good
some people would say it's it's the same
for the kid
some people might have this view where
like the heterosexual couple is slightly
better
but almost
everyone would agree
about the things that are really bad now
of course there's homophobic people who
would go no no no no what dave ruben and
his husband are doing it just it's bad
it's bad that's it
but
given that there are what is it is it
300 000 kids in the foster care system
or whatever
the
why why are we
whether you grade
a heterosexual couple in the situation i
described the same as gay couple in the
same situation
or slightly off different
why are we even arguing about that
because there's 300 000 kids in the
foster care system and either of those
scenarios
is way better
than what any of these kids are in in
almost every situation and then you go
to like what i mean i just don't even it
seems like a way
to say gay parenting isn't that good
just like to crowbar it in even though
like
what you know
two financially stable moms yeah when i
say when i say a gay couple i i you know
gay lesbian okay
anyway
crazy stuff going on with jordan
peterson it's it's really really strange
chakaseki says peterson has had gender
affirming surgery with his hairline
so him going after paige is pathetic cry
bully benzo kermit
did he have a hair hair transplant i
didn't know that
history anthropology says children are
best raised by a community or tribe not
just two parents something something it
takes a village okay yeah that's another
i mean you could say that you go
actually there's there's other better
alternatives
okay i want to say thank you to
skittlestu for gifting five twitch
subscriptions also
mur and miranda nicole and mark lawrence
that's seven putting us at 35 if you're
just joining us we're kind of cleaning
out the computer going through a bunch
of different things that i have going on
if we get to 100 supporters today
i will guarantee another stream this
week potentially the trump rally on
saturday night three ways to support
number one and the most direct and
pleasurable is you get a membership at
joinedpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indict to get a discount
second way to support if you're watching
on twitch particularly if you have
amazon prime you get a twitch prime
subscription it's free to you
and that will count and then lastly
you can count double if you make a
pledge on patreon patreon
which is patreon.com davidpakmanshow
each of those will count as two
on our path to a hundred just something
to keep in mind
all right let's keep going with other
things oh
here's a rant that my colleague john
sent me from the ben shapiro show he's
apparently flipping out about something
related to elmo
um
i haven't seen this let's check it out
children's tv it used to be sort of an
innocent place to put your kids in front
of the tv not have to worry that they
were going to imbibe trans ideology or
or vax for children propaganda well no
longer because the left has discovered
that it really really likes
indoctrinating kids and whatever their
preferred policies of the day are
we have two excellent examples for you
today so example number one apparently
sesame street is now pushing kids to
facts they are doing this by wait a
second is he now calling his thing the
bonus hour oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad
is that now
the bonus hour
wait a second that sounds a little weird
to me
i don't know we're gonna have to look
into that
anyway let's continue by having elmo's
dad explain to elmo that a vaccine for
covet is a great idea now listen
i vaxxed my kids for mmr i'm a big
advocate of that because these are
childhood diseases that can be
eradicated nationwide only by giving
kids the vaccines covid is a very
different story it is a disease that
proportionately
basically does not affect kids it is
disease where kids get it but they don't
die from it
it just as a general number the number
of kids who have died from this is way
lower than the number of kids who die
every year from pneumonia in the same
period
if you're talking about who the disease
affects the answer is people who are
really old plus
the vaccines do not prevent transmission
so there's that
so why would it be necessary for
children to get the vaccine but the left
has decided that everyone must have the
vaccine as a sign of faith as a sign of
faith in tough science you must you must
take your two-year-old and jack him full
of a vax that has not had any
longitudinal jacom or jillum jeez
testing
and you must do this to prevent a risk
that does not really exist for your
two-year-old you must do it and now
sesame street is going to preach to you
by having elmo get the shot
so um
here is here's elmo talking to his dad
by the way i did not know that having
kids full of vaccine it's very strange
language guys elmo's dad apparently has
a soul patch and really likes listening
to
green day or something i i don't know
what almost dad's story is but he i like
green day actually he really needs to
clean up if he wishes to ever become a
bank executive here we go
now daddy has super duper bandages just
like hell now
you were super duper today getting your
covert vaccine elmo yeah there was a
little pinch but it was okay emma was
really glad to have daddy and
you know i haven't seen sesame street in
probably 25 years
this is not elmo's voice that i remember
is it like a different voice actor now
doing elmo this i just it sounds
completely different to me maybe david
there with him baby david where are you
i had a lot of questions about elmo
getting the covert vaccine was it safe
was it the right decision
i talked to our pediatrician so i could
make the right choice
i learned that elmo getting vaccinated
is the best way to keep himself our
friends neighbors and everyone else
healthy and enjoying the things they
love oh daddy oh emma and baby david
have a question
can we have a hug oh come here son uh
everyone loves you daddy i love you too
it's okay to have questions about covid
vaccines for your kids get the latest
facts by speaking to your pediatrician
or health care provider
i mean i'll no it isn't you literally
just said that you should just go get
your kids facts almost like ah
i have a band-aid just like you out of
my heart
guys i don't think i can do it
i don't think i can keep going we're
halfway through the clip but i think
i've got a bail
man i
i'll try 30 more seconds i guess
see the good news for elmo is that elmo
is a uh is a stuffed animal so
he actually is not vulnerable to side
effects from the vaccine at all so
really almost shouldn't be worried about
this at all but it's always fun when you
see your public dollar spent on behalf
of a profitable corporation like sesame
street in order to push forward
propaganda about how small children need
vaccines in order to prevent it's a way
to keep the neighborhood safe how
how
it doesn't this is you know one of the
things that i i don't really watch ben
shapiro content
but one of the things that i kind of
always thought was
it's very entertaining and like
compelling so i understand why it pulls
people in
this is pretty boring and lame actually
isn't it like am i am i just
desensitized to it but this isn't even
that interest like i don't agree with
the things he's saying but it's also
just kind of like i don't even care
am i misreading it
it's just like is this that interesting
yeah it's boring and pointless all right
let's move on let's get the hell out of
here let me thank some people first
before we move on thanks to griff wire
and f york m for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at 37.
ally
or is it ali or ali prugar just made a
patreon pledge those count double so
that puts it puts us at 39. i also want
to say thanks to terry schwerin who just
gifted a subscription and juan just
gifted a subscription putting us at 41
as i mentioned earlier
if we get to 100 we will lock in another
stream for the week
sinsu says via super chat
the ideal setting for raising kids has
nothing to do with the gender of the
parents or the number of parents the
ideal is a living mature stable
financially adequate home
well said sinsu
appreciate that
who's more painful to listen to shapiro
or peterson damn that's tough
that stuff i think peterson's more
annoying in that he'll use a hundred
words where five would get the message
across and that's just kind of
it's pedantic in a sense
um
shapiro probably says crazier things to
a degree but that's a tough one that's a
tough one all right let's continue
um okay no so we did this already
ah on the podcast today and on youtube
in a clip published earlier
we had um
we had some highlights from
the
wyoming primary debate in which liz
cheney was the only sane person
there is competition for one of the
craziest uh elections going on
here is the republican primary debate
from the arizona gubernatorial
you've got to see this that that wacky
woman uh carrie lake
is one of the candidates check this out
they closed my business down but you
know what i didn't listen i kept it open
you didn't have to listen people you
didn't have to listen i'd actually like
to ask everybody this is carrie lake
here on the stage if they would agree we
had a corrupt stolen election raise your
hand
never happened
god they talk over me and i'm italian
that shouldn't happen
you know i'm irish
okay you know what oh boy
why not get
high-tech people that are going to be on
the machines that are republicans a
democrat republican high-tech people
that are going to be on the machines
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines it's supervisors
equal amounts it happens that we have
parties looking over that's right
they're doing it now no no they they're
actually
hundreds 200 000 minimum ballots were
trafficked by mules
no
there's no evidence of that there is no
evidence of that there is absolutely no
evidence of that
oh an honest election
mom mommy
guys you're not letting her say the
crazy things
i feel like i'm on an snl i thought that
they were actually trafficked by zebras
that's the weird thing all of this talk
of mules i didn't think that was the
method get here we only take control of
the debates we are joking no no no
carrie i don't want it i'm happy to do
it i know you would be happy to do it
listen i haven't been on a stage with
this many women since i've been to a
baby shower it's been a while i don't
know how that's going to go over scott
but we'll let
oh my god
and we will ban men
at hang um let's talk about
what
do you think republican voters want a
candidate when the moderator is this
visibly frustrated
you know things aren't going
particularly well who doesn't even
believe in the vote
i don't believe this primary has been
fair i can tell you that otherwise i
wouldn't have launched the losses oh
he's calling fraud on this primary
campaign is a movement we're going to
show up and vote in droves they're going
to have to cheat even harder in order to
try to win this your campaign's a psyop
uh
please put everything your campaign is a
psyop
i feel like this is a spoof honestly go
ahead finish what you were saying now
that i agree with
that i agree with hold on that was a
crazy i gotta go back because that was
so crazy
he says it's a psyop and then she says
this is a spoof it's been fair i can
tell you that otherwise i wouldn't have
launched the lawsuit our campaign is a
movement we're gonna show up and vote in
droves they're gonna have to cheat even
harder in order to try to win this your
campaign's a psyop
policy
first of all put everything i feel like
this is a spoof honestly go ahead finish
what you were saying please oh is this a
spoof town no it's not vince are you
sure am wow okay she's acting like she's
not also saying crazy things but she's
saying things that are just as crazy
pro-life from conception to death
and i believe no exceptions for rape or
incest well that's a gray area i don't
know that's a personal decision for a
person right but would it be no but the
thing is if you make it illegal it's no
longer anyone's choice
what was that woman's name
well why can't we treat human life in
the same way that we would treat alien
life that we discovered
how would you there's a reason what
what
we don't always invite scott because
he's polling at zero percent no
no that's funny that's actually pretty
funny that we don't we don't usually
invite him because he's po i've got to
hear that again that i actually liked
why can't we treat human life in the
same way that we would treat alien life
that we discovered
how would you there's a reason we don't
always invite scott because he's polling
at zero percent
that's dude that is i like that that i
like one percent this is one person
scott please the polls aren't real
and we know you can't respond to a
closing statement the only
they wanted to respond to a closing
statement oh these people are dangerous
these people are completely dangerous
kind of drag i've ever dressed in is a
business suit or construction work
clothes
i've never aspired to be elvis presley
wow well if that doesn't get him at
least five more votes i don't know what
will all right that's it that's it
that's it
wow
that's completely insane that's that
i've never seen anything like that
uh this went better than envision that's
funny
wow
i i don't even know what to make of that
i i just i just have no idea that's
bizarre
thanks to twitchy twitcher tony for the
twitch prime subscription number 42 42
very much appreciate that today's coupon
code is indict
indict
um
let's continue
candace owens used to be pro-choice
she is no longer pro-choice
let's listen to her explain why
oh thanks to juho jay
for the twitch prime subscription number
43. oh and let me do one super chat real
quick
guitar hero says horrified by republican
wins and seriously thinking of moving
and establishing a life outside the u.s
does that make me a coward no i mean i
think about the same thing
doesn't make you a coward makes you
sensible quite frankly hello and welcome
so as you can see i'm back from
maternity leave i have not yet had the
baby but i felt that this issue was too
important
what the issue of roe v wade being
overturned and the shrieking that is
taking place wait she's she's having a
baby is she with that is she with that
british guy that she was with at one
point
be very interested in who the father is
nobody knows oh thanks to hillary lee
for the patreon pledge those count
double so that's number 45. also thanks
to andrew geisis or gises you're number
46 today let's continue with candace all
across the world i wanted to add my
voice to this i want down my voice by
telling you guys as you may know i used
to man good thing i had a baby to cancel
out her baby right i mean that whatever
vote we now got one back so now it we're
we've canceled out the baby she's gonna
have as a voter that's that's a good
thing be pro-choice for the majority of
my life
why i am now pro-life
these are my five reasons that i am no
longer pro-choice okay
the first reason is because
most women get abortions under duress or
because they are fearful
that's uh
vague and untrue
vague and untrue
my first introduction to the topic of
abortion was when i was about 10 years
old and a cousin of mine fell pregnant
she wanted to despite how young she was
about 15 or 16 years old keep her child
but the family said no okay that's
called an anecdote
family aunts uncles everyone flew in to
meet with her and speak to her and tell
her how this would ruin her life
there were a lot of tears she wanted her
child and ultimately she didn't end up
keeping it
my second introduction to the topic so
she's against she's she's now against
abortion because
her cousin didn't want an abortion
and she falsely claims
most abortions happen under duress it is
untrue so her first reason is just based
on
wrong facts of abortion i must have been
about 14 years old maybe just entering
high school and it was a similar
situation a cousin of mine fell pregnant
now she wasn't a teenager and she knew
that she wanted to keep her son
but a bad boyfriend didn't want her to
keep him he put a lot of pressure on her
to have an abortion and it
actually amounted to him breaking into
her home threatening her trying to
physically harm her to convince her to
get this procedure
so far be it from these depictions these
media depictions that we have people
pretending that women are flowery and
skipping into the clinic
nobody pretends that women are flowery
and skipping into the clinic in fact
that's the reason why we're against
protesters at family planning centers
because it's like it's often not really
a party for the women
so that's why we don't want protesters
there
uh so far she turned against abortion
because of two anecdotes that may or may
not be true and it's what they want to
do they're feeling empowered they just
want to have this procedure they're
going to feel great
no that's not what's happening
you know that i know that i've known six
more women since that i've gotten
abortion it's always the same scenario
moms upsets your parents are upset your
friends tell you that your whole life is
going to be ruined your boyfriend tells
you that you're going to ruin his life
now
even if these anecdotes were true and
even if it were true that some women get
abortion under duress
that's not a reason to make it illegal
like it's it doesn't
did none of this is believable
or a good reason to make abortion
illegal even if true
none of it is
even believable obviously
women are operating under duress it's a
game of peer pressure so point one and
two are the same point the celebrities
are lying to you
they're treating us like the cigarette
campaign back in the 60s oh how cool you
just get an abortion it's like smoking
cigarettes so cool
right my body my choice these are forms
of propaganda they are lies the truth is
that abortions harm people they harm
women
physically and spiritually the majority
of women are being harmed spiritually by
the pressure to get an abortion
untrue no evidence which brings me to
reason number two wait i thought that
was already number two my reason number
two as to why i'm no longer pro-choice
is because we're not even debating
abortion anymore in this country and you
know that's true i was speaking to my
husband earlier you guys know he's from
the united kingdom and it shocks him to
see how far women are going threatening
to kill supreme court justices standing
outside screaming and screaming like
they've been possessed by a d whoa
screaming are you nuts amen
in fact take a look at this picture this
is a picture from outside the supreme
court house and you have a woman that is
looks to be about seven or eight months
pregnant maybe even nine months pregnant
and she's written on her body not yet a
human now what i don't not that it
really matters
but wasn't this
like a trolling effort
i don't actually know that was this even
was this woman serious i don't even know
it doesn't even matter it doesn't change
anything but
was this for real or was this a troll
this is the woman who did this
like i care so little about it in terms
of the broader debate but
she was making a legal point
okay anyway she has that written on her
belly not yet a human
and she's holding a small child that
looks to about one years old
what is that if that's not a demonic
possession right what sort of a woman
would do that right yeah no she's
demonically
candace owens is very rationally telling
us why she's now against abortion and
mentioning that some of the people in
favor of abortion are demonically
possessed perfectly sensible perfectly
natural
what we're talking about in america now
when you have people that are
legislating saying that women should be
allowed to get an abortion up to nine
months when the child is nine months in
the womb i'm nine months pregnant i'm
due to give birth in a week and a half
right now
the idea that i could stroll into a
clinic and there are people that believe
that i should be able to just have this
child removed from me this do you guys
know how rare that is first of all when
you actually talk to
uh obs
if you said to them hey
if so let's just imagine when she says
that she's a week and a half from her
due date let's assume that her due date
is 40 weeks so that she's at 38 and a
half weeks okay
if you go into a hospital right now and
you go to labor and delivery i just did
this right okay so not me i i wasn't the
pregnant one by the way but and you go
yeah i'm 38 and a half weeks um give me
an abortion
is there a is is your life in danger
like
obs have already testified like we don't
we don't do that we don't just do nobody
has ever done it and if someone if
someone did we would be like what are
you even talking about right now we
would be like is it a psych eval is it
i'd
the legat i don't even know if that
would be legal i genuinely don't know it
probably depends on state to state
i've never heard of it
and every ob that has been asked about
this scenario goes i wouldn't do that
it's never happened and i wouldn't do it
um
38 and a half weeks ah it changed my
mind just give me an abortion
it's unheard of it's unheard of
a child that i feel kicking in my belly
every second of the day i'm not talking
about abortion we're talking about child
sacrifice
in fact it reminds me
of a book that i read about native
americans specifically aztecs and the
horrific child and human sacrifices that
took place
they actually committed on one day
because they built this temple
26 000 people were sacrificed to raise a
temple that they were building what does
that have to do with abortion 26 000
lives sacrificed on the altar to their
belief in gods
now we look back at that and we think
that sounds so barbaric that could never
happen in society today it's 2022.
but in america yeah there's
approximately 890
000 abortions per a year i know it's not
for a temple we're not building some big
temple and sacrificing these children to
gods no we're doing it for ready
convenience
for i'm not ready to be a mom
i don't want to be a father so get an
abortion for this is going to end my
career this baby would get in the way of
man this is i don't even want to subject
you to the rest of it but her reasons
are very dumb
tangentially or not at all related to
abortion
and just based on assertions that are
demonstrably untrue it's you know i
don't know and as i've said before a
couple people said a couple of you came
to me with tears in your eyes and you
said david sir now that you've had a
baby has your view on abortion changed
um
and the answer is no it hasn't in fact
it seems more like what why would anyone
say that this should be illegal
um
you know
we didn't procure
an abortion
and now there's a live baby it's a real
person but even if you say david
imagine if at four weeks
you had gotten an abortion
the isn't that now that you know the
baby i mean no at four weeks it was not
a person and it was certainly not a baby
it it would have been fine i never would
have i mean it's like no it didn't
change my mind at all
um
yeah it should be legal yeah my view has
not changed in any way
in any way all right so there's candace
owens let's let's move on because this
is all pretty um pretty vile
i want to say thank you to a few other
people
blueberry babe has just gifted five
subscriptions on twitch go go gonzo
kahali
braided dragon peck w
and scarecrow have signed up
pec w gifted two and thieves down
has also signed up that's 13 putting us
at 59 i really appreciate that
also a big thank you to blake misquita
and henry gray hawk
for signing up and gifting a membership
on my website one each respectively
very appreciate very much appreciate
that saturation point art says i got a
boxer puppy over the weekend and named
her mango she cost much more than a bag
of mangoes under anyone's regime boxer
puppies are very cute congratulations
uh okay
um would you ken paxton
says he is ready to fight to overturn
lawrence
listen to this
would you as attorney general be
comfortable defending a law that once
again outlawed sodomy that questioned
lawrence again or griswold
or gay marriage uh that came from the
state legislature to to put to the test
what justice thomas said
yeah i mean there's all kinds of issues
here but certainly the supreme court has
stepped into issues that i don't think
there was any constitutional provision
dealing with they were legislative
issues and this is one of those issues
and there may be more
i guess he's sort of saying like maybe
he would be okay with sodomy laws
sodomy laws by the way are completely
bonkers sodomy law defines certain
sexual acts as crime
the precise sexual acts meant by the
term sodomy are rarely spelled out in
the law but they're understood by courts
to include any act deemed unnatural or
immoral
sodomy typically includes anal sex oral
sex and bestiality
in practice sodomy laws have rarely been
enforced against heterosexual couples
and have mostly been used to target
homosexual couples there's nothing
smaller government
and a lighter touch
than saying
here's the things you can do in your
bedroom and here's the things you can't
sexually
that small government
small government
okay
a bunch of people have written to me
about gavin newsom gavin newsom is the
democratic governor of california he's
not the most progressive guy
but he's pretty damn clever and while i
am if we think about 2024
um i don't believe joe biden is running
for reelection and i've said already i
the people i'm not saying these are the
most electable people but i i like jamie
raskin
uh i like john ossoff you know there's
other people i like
gavin newsom is someone i wouldn't
immediately
write off
in terms of electability i think he's
very smart and i think that
it would be interesting if he ran
although i'm not like a fan of gavin
newsom and his politics are different
than my politics all i'm saying is
i think it's conceivable he could do
well against someone like desantis okay
that that's all i'm saying and people
david oh denu newsom is scum
let's
take it down a notch okay let's take it
down a notch he's been running ads in
florida and in florida he's been running
them in both states
and uh okay let's check out one of them
dependence day so let's talk about
what's going on in america freedom it's
under attack in your state republican
leaders they're banning books yanking it
harder to vote restricting speech in
classrooms even criminalizing women and
doctors i urge all of you living in
florida to join the fight or join us in
california but we still believe in
freedom free isn't that the best
appealing to florida residents and
saying come to where there's freedom
california of course the right wing idea
is
florida is where there's freedom
california is nanny state all this
terrible up now california has a budget
surplus
economically it's looking better than
florida
um
so many i mean people move to both
states
uh but
you know the idea that oh florida's just
doing so much better florida doesn't do
well in access to health care on and on
and on freedom of speech freedom to
choose freedom from hate and the freedom
to love don't let them take your freedom
paid for by news and for california
governor 2022 okay he's running for
governor now but there are rumblings
about could he be a 2024 contender
potentially
uh and so that's kind of the genesis of
this i think it's interesting he's not
like my favorite politician i i the
thing is i don't really care like when
people say he's scum and he did the
you know he went to the french laundry
for dinner during the pandemic and all
this stuff fine yeah i don't have to
like this guy as a person
uh i mean is everything bill clinton did
stuff i would think this is the best
thing to do and moral no but
we're talking about politics here and i
don't know these people personally and i
don't really care about you know
it's just like
could he potentially be an interesting
candidate and i think there's the
potential for that that's all it is all
right everybody relax
thank you to overa dev for the twitch
prime subscription you're number 62
today i also want to say a big thank you
to lisa raider lisa just signed up at
joinpakman.com
with the coupon code indite as a
reminder we're almost two thirds of the
way there if we get to 100 supporters
today that includes
joinpakman.com twitch and patreon
we will guarantee another stream this
week which potentially will be the trump
rally on saturday night in alaska also
thanks to bosch
for the twitch prime subscription number
64.
super chat
jack says david is someone in
pennsylvania i'm really worried about
the gubernatorial election unlike dr oz
doug mastriano has a lot of grassroots
enthusiasm jack you're absolutely right
i am horrified that uh
listen
i'm not seeing like big energy behind
josh shapiro who's the democratic
nominee for pennsylvania governor
and i am seeing
a lot
a lot of enthusiasm from lunatics
behind mastriano who is a monstrous
monstrous dangerous guy
so i am very very much concerned about
that as well let's look at a couple of
other things here here's dave portnoy
from bar stool sports bar stool sports
appeals to all sorts of different folks
but it does have a certain right wing
sort of energy to it he came out and
ranted and said i don't like this roe v
wade being overturned thing let's listen
to what he had to say and then i'm going
to show you some of the replies on
twitter check this out okay emergency
press conference uh roe vs wade just got
overturned let me start by saying this
is a dave portnoy press conference this
doesn't reflect marcel alright barcelo
is 300 whatever people they all may
think certain ways is just me how i feel
i feel like i have to speak on this
issue i already talked about a little
bit to me this is just pure
insanity right pure incentive we are
going backwards in time yep we are
literally going backwards in time
it makes no sense how anybody thinks
it's their right to tell a woman what to
do with her body i just don't get it to
take away the ability to make informed
decisions on how they want to live their
lives is bananas i know people will be
like well no it's a constitutional issue
they're just giving it to the states
well like what 20 states are saying
they're going to overturn it right away
and what if you're poor in that state
and you can't go to another state and
things like that it's just nuts to me
not to mention the same people are
saying you know
they want to take it away and overturn
it are also like gotta protect guns
because the constitution
at what point do you look at the
constitution and say hey this was
written by people who had slaves maybe
not everything is exactly to a t in the
constitution like a million years from
now you're going to use the document
written in the it's just not it's
completely not okay so he goes on for
another minute you get the gist of it
perfectly reasonable what he's saying
here
what do we think we're gonna find in the
replies
this is the pizza guy that's exactly
right let's see what happens
ignorance mouthy mom says ignorance
let's see what else we've got
didn't the government tell men and women
to wear certain clothing a mask
let's see what else we got
dave do some more research bud it's not
overturning abortion it's saying it's
not constitutional it's not and leaving
it to the states to decide
options abstinence condoms vasectomy
hysterectomy oral contraceptive pills
responsibility
accurate reply these are all next on the
supreme court agenda well said
my god educate yourself on what this
ruling actually means wow portnoy's
audience turning on him
in the first five seconds you explained
that you have no idea how a
representative republic works
the rest is just gab
like most people you can tell dave
didn't read the ruling or the reasoning
behind it
you realize abortion literally takes
away the most basic right the right to
life
um
okay so anyway
you can see
9 out of 10 19 out of 20
replies
are furious stay in your lane if you
don't know about politics and about the
decision stay out of politics that says
that's what noah says
hook up culture connoisseur sees lack of
on-demand abortion as a problem
yikes
so there it is the bar stool audience
not thrilled not thrilled
with uh dave portnoy's position on this
steph has made a two dollar pledge on
patreon those count double that puts us
at 66. all right everybody that's
everything i had for today we have
cleaned out the computer it is now clean
we've cleaned it out almost like um
almost like an injection of sorts
supposing we hit the body with a
tremendous uh very powerful light
and then i see the disinfectant is there
a way we can do something like that
by
injection inside or
apply
light and heat to
cure right
we've done a cleaning of the computer
i may see you guys back here the podcast
is out of control the podcast is
actually on fire um so i'm so glad to be
back and hopefully it will all continue
thank you everybody for joining me oh
and by the way i will soon be announcing
my next trip the united states will be
the first nation to land an astronaut on
ours we are going to nars ladies and
gentlemen i will see you very soon
obama
[Music]